welcome to this video playing time
waster from the UK okay the various soft
opening yeah this stuff is getting
popular with Bishop f4 yeah I played a 6
I think this is how they play it on
trying to prevent any funny business on
b5 so I'm going to get the porn back
eventually this is good news oh ok so
hmm that's not good I don't want to give
up the bishop really it's not so much
about the bishop pair that the dark
squares look terrible that play Bishop
c5 95 Greene 85 I rather do this yeah
yeah but it should be an ok position
should be so bad it looks it's uncanny
it looks really a lot like a queen's
gambit with Bishop f4 ok what to do be
four now Queen a5 is not possible due to
be form d 4d 4b form not good ok come on
keep it simple
just take them and what now yeah i can
trade even more stuff which looks really
really boring or b-five there should be
seven but this is a this is a shaky
setup okay I know it's not it's not very
exciting but it is probably the the wise
thing to do check a little bit behind in
development but this type of position is
rather well known it is very difficult
for wide to extract anything as I cover
d 787 and d 8 and my bad plan very short
term it's like King evade f6e 5 and then
his bishop in fact will be out of play
so he has to do something against that
yeah this is an interesting idea 94 may
be coming and e5 I cannot play I cannot
play f6 okay so I wonder maybe I should
just take yeah not what I want to do
really but 94 2d6 hmm I can play age 69
t4 t5 though
study can go to the 60 kv-5 Bishop 33
okay yeah it's still it's still seems
dependable yeah be sure 5m I need to
need to provoke this 96 movie I want to
take then king e 7 i'd be should be six
now we should be six what's what's your
big point here I don't don't get it King
d6 King d6 winning an exchange here or
not what is the point king d 6 B 4 B 6 I
don't see it and let's see it v6b should
be six I take on c5 I don't know what
I'm overlooking here maybe nothing
it's not easy i mean from a technical
point of view react okay i need to put
those on light squares and then you have
a i have a direct invasion route for the
king king deef yeah i need to need to
enter here quickly try to get the pawn
this this might even be not that
difficult when i get the a pawn it it's
not that that much that that that much
of a problem getting a quick pass on
cooking a for there might be Bishop d7 i
can take both ports yeah okay so that
that is basically that should be enough
already Bishop g7 i'll just go h5 it it
takes takes a moment that's all you get
sap SRM self
what I don't want to allow us on the
king coming entering the position so i'm
using this this opinion and two for some
45 here back here next oopsie aid ok
block on the light squares check here
and now a five a five to get the pass on
King b3 and rooks III and then capturing
on till the check I capture f5 yeah
that's not going to be enough or is
there something something simpler time
morning and I'm not really yeah okay
check check oh this is this I overlooked
not good
check oh wow that there was much there
were much easier solutions to that
really white resigns yeah yeah this
feels like slightly weird win because I
was just having this slightly worse
position with no a big big anything but
yeah it is really like this is hard to
hard to break down black gum is fairly
fairly stable here and this oh I can
play five Wow everybody should calculate
some time I can play you five yeah of
course I can because there's so much
hanging nah just winning a PC I'm
Jacqueline yeah this is a total a bunch
of liabilities in whites position i will
just win apiece him for two bonds but ok
so i was i was content with that i'm
thinking that i can hold this which is
probably probably true 96 is making
things relatively easy for me I think
stuff like bishop d 5 and so on white is
still more comfortable after that it's
it's equal really but okay we shouldn't
oops you shouldn't go there okay I'm
back this was a totally unimportant
phone call yeah em a group t5 of course
is a strange decision ready can just go
back and then after Bishop b6 um this
should be three try from there i mean
this is this is already very resilient
how to break down but of course white
should never ever lose or anything white
is just still a bit better
here yeah he was running into this this
thing there was probably a better way to
try to defend this should be six maybe
yeah here yeah this is this is a fairly
simple wind which I managed to almost
screw up I mean it's not easy but I was
close to it I was awesome they forgot
that check he can block can knock things
here look aged four is the easiest but
yeah I forgot about it should be five
Wow why what is what you seven is a draw
you must be kidding why is this it wrong
because of the Bishop b5 threat Wow yeah
I really screwed this up I'm wow Luke c3
rook c8 wins easily but here e seven oh
no wow yeah this is a draw yeah it's a
draw what can i do if i take it of
course he sees just in time so not not
possible and if i go oops if i go here
we should be five and i can do that but
oops here Queen chechik yeah and I mean
this this is probably a draw yeah that
must be at all my king is so far away
from the port this is a draw wow I
almost screwed this up or I screwed it
up he could have taken advantage of the
offer prov the mistake Wow okay well
thanks for watching